وفي زاويه اخرى من الحرب يبدو ان روسيا
حصلت جزئيا على ما تريد الحديث هنا عن بث
الفرقه في حلف الناتو فاموسكو قالتها اكثر
من مره صراحه بان الحرب في اوكرانيا هي
حرب بينها وبين الحلف لا شك في ذلك فحلف
شمال الاطلسي هو العدو التاريخي اللدود
لموسكو التي لا تتردد في التمديد بحركاته
التوسعيه في انضمامه اي عضو جديد للحلف
يشكل هاجسا مؤرقا بالنسبه لروسيا اخر
راغبين في الانضمام الى الحلف هم السويد
وفيلم ده لا تاني رفع بوجه بوجهيه مع
اردوغان الفيتا التركي فما فشله في تحقيقه
بوتن ربما ينجح فيه اردوغان الذي تحول الى
حجر عثره حقيقي يحول دون انضمام الدولتين
او احداهما على الاقل حتى الان الى الحياه
الاكثر من ذلك فان التعنت التركي بدا في
تشتيت مجهودات البلدين الى درجه الانقسام
هل سينكي بدات بالتفكير فعليا في السعي
الى الانضمام للحلف بشكل فردي الاعلان جاء
على لسان وزير الخارجيه الفنلندي بك
هافيستو الذي قال ان على بلاده التفكيره
في الانضمام في الانضمام الى الحلف بشكل
مستقل عن السؤال
ندا بان حظوظها اقوى من السويد لاسيه ما
بعد استبعاد الرئيس التركي دعم طلب السويد
بسبب عدم امتثالها لطلباته وتنامي المشاعر
المعاديه للمسلمين فيها حتى ولو اعلنت
سويد انها تريد استمرار الحوار مع تركيا
علمه ان معارضه تركيه نابعه بالاساس من
مطالبها بخصوص تسليم السويد عناصر من حزب
العمال الكردستاني الذي تصنفه انقره جماعه
ارهابيه وعرضه عكس السويد فان فنلندا لا
تواجههم مانعه تركيه كبيره وهو ما اكدته
رئيسه الوزراء الفنلنديه سنمارين حين قالت
انه لا توجد مشكله كبيره لتركيا مع فنلندا
وربما تتعلق المشكلات بالسويس بعيدا عن
ملف الانضمام المنفرد لفنلندا فان الموضوع
بشكل عام مرتبط بشكل اساسي بقرار الذي
سيتاجل على الارجح الى ما بعد اجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه والتي من
المفترض ان تجرى في شهر مايو المقبل ما
يعني ان على هالكيلم الانتظار لاشهر
الاخرى حتى تتفرغ انقره لمضوعهما طبعا هذا
نوع من الانقسام المعلن بين انهيته لكنه
هناك انقساما اعمق راويه ربما يتعلق بامور
اخطر وهي السلاح وليس فقط بالعضويات